chacun ici mon père et je me trompe
boutros ghali
et on
cet essai là
la porte
bonsoir ancien premier ministre d'israël
organisateurs des accords d'oslo prix
nobel de la paix boutros boutros ghali
bonsoir bonsoir ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères d'égypte lors du
voyage de sadate à jérusalem
ancien secrétaire général de l'onu andré
versaille fondateur et directeur des
éditions complexe
vous publiez boutros boutros ghali
shimon peres 60 ans de conflit
israélo-arabe témoignage pour l'histoire
ans un bouquin passionnant parce que ce
sont des entretiens croisés entre deux
acteurs essentiels de l'histoire du
monde
deux adversaires sur un ton beaucoup
plus politique que diplomatique
absolument c'est la première fois je
crois qu'il ya même je crois au xxème
siècle deux personnes de ce niveau là de
cette importance là qui décident de se
rencontrer alors que la guerre n'est pas
terminé même s'il ya une paix entre
l'egypte et israël c est quand même peu
froide et le monde arabe n'est pas en
paix avec israël aujourd'hui c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire est donc malgré tout
ils prennent le risque de parler
ensemble et c'est à dire de de tricoter
ensemble leur mémoire si on peut dire
ils ont tous les deux le même âge dont
qu'ils ont vécu une par définition les
mêmes choses au même âge mais chacun
d'un côté de la frontière
ce qui est important aussi c'est que
boutros boutros ghali est un égyptien ce
n'est pas un palestinien
on voit trop souvent le cas ce conflit
comme uniquement ils seraient les
palestiniens ce qu'il est devenu
essentiellement à l'heure actuelle mais
quand on voit sur 60 ans sur 70 soir
c'est beaucoup plus en conflit israélo
arabe
donc ça me semblait important de les
mettre en seul essai de mettre ensemble
pour avoir un dialogue qui comme vous
dites n'est pas diplomatique mais
politique c'est à dire qu'ils se disent
vraiment les choses ce n'est pas à
fleurets mouchetés
c'est vraiment et on a décidé de leur
ego mais de ne rien comme et qu' il y à
une opposition frontale
même si elle est respectueuse bien sûr
on a vraiment aussi les deux mentalités
la montagne serait la mentalité
israélienne et la mentalité arabe
c'est très réussi un peu le cas bravo
toujours merdes à l'initiative l'érable
alors ce qui est clair l'ensemble du
livre cvo éveil respectifs à la
politique
boutros vous avait 13 ans quand en 1935
l'italie de mussolini envahi l'ethiopie
du négus et ça vous révoltent parce que
vous y voyez la tutelle de l'europe sur
le monde africain et le monde arabe
ce qu'on appellera par la suite le tiers
monde oui j'ai à ce moment acheter des
timbres ont ramassé de l'argent j'avais
des parents qui sont partis comme
volontaire des médecins donc j'ai vécu 7
et lorsque le négus à passer par le
canal de suez pour aller à la société
des nations
j'ai pleuré pendant toute une journée
oui ça vous a marqué ça beaucoup oui
beaucoup
il a été très important par la suite oui
c'est à dire que à ce moment je ne
savais pas qu'est ce que c'est que le
colonialisme j'ai eu aucune idée mais je
me sentais plus près de l'ethiopie que
de l'italie
voilà alors shimon vous vous êtes né en
pologne dans une famille sioniste vous
est-elle en palestine
vous aviez 11 ans c'était en 1934 et à
l'époque dites vous la terre était
traversé par une population sans
domicile fixe il n'y avait pas de peuple
distinct
il y avait les arabes de la région et
pour israël c'était une terre sans
peuple pour un peuple sans terre
c'est vrai j'étais sûr que nous sommes
sel
il avait quelques villages arabes mais
pas beaucoup
en principe c'était in et à un endroit
complètement juive qui parle
complètement libre et c'est sr1 g
sensations pour moi pour nous tous parce
que nous avons ne reviennent pas ce mot
vers les terres mais aussi vers la
langue la langue est peut-être plus
important que le terme m c'est les
fondations des cultures alors en 1945 à
la fin de la guerre le monde découvre le
système nazi et le génocide des juifs
mais pour les arabes dites-vous boutros
boutros ghali c'est un problème entre
européens et vous dites en créant israël
finalement
les occidentaux se mette en règle avec
leur conscience mais ce n'est pas un
problème arabe c'est ça d'autant plus
que nous commençons à y vivre une
période de décolonisation et du départ
des étrangers et nous voyons de nouveaux
étrangers qui viennent s'installer alors
les américains on apprend ça dans le
bouquin son sont partagés en fait sur le
sort à réserver à israël il ya le
président truman qui est qui et pour mes
marche à celui du plan marshall est
contre il ya une chose comme qui est
très intéressante c'est de savoir
pourquoi ce sont les juifs qui
réussissent à emporter le morceau si je
peux me parle de parler comme ça puisque
les juges sont quand même des 6 mai au
lendemain de la guerre le monde arabe
représente une force quand même beaucoup
plus important que le mouvement sioniste
qui avait avant la guerre n'a pas
vraiment d'importance
et c'est eux qui vont réussir
diplomatiquement à avoir une influence
sur truman et une avance très très
important puisque si c'est romane qui va
véritablement faire que la le plan de
partage va se produire
donc il est intéressant de voir que et
c'est justement celle de la liste fait
boutros boutros ghali il dit c'est vrai
que les que les que les juifs sont
décimés messieurs qui était aux états
unis avaient toutes les toutes les
ficelles connaissait exactement avaient
tous les réseaux et connaissait la le
monde diplomatique alors que le monde
arabe était beaucoup plus provincialiser
et ne savait pas qu'il ait colonisé et
économique est entièrement colonisé ils
n'étaient pas indépendants
il y avait des troupes d'occupation dans
tous les paysages
oui mais ce que vous dites france était
colonisée par les ottomans par les turcs
we will et les peuples pas les siennes
jamais n'avait pas le goût de paiement
alors le 29 novembre 1947 l'onu se
prononce pour la partition 55 % de la
palestine est donné aux juifs qui ne
représente que 37 % de la population et
45 pour le champ aux palestiniens
évidemment
le principe est refusée aussi bien par
les palestiniens que par le monde arable
et il faut aussi distinguer les
résolutions des nations unies étaient
pourris n'est tard yves joly est pour un
état arabe palestinien
et quand les pales les arabes à vannes
qatar et à l'est cette pièce des ternes
et l aisselle il avait beaucoup d autres
pour le monde juif c'était les selles
pièce historiquement et aussi si vous
voulez dans le foie comme ça ne paie pas
comparer un monde arabe
c'est grand c'est l'âge et nous imputer
peuple sur un très petit pièces de terre
quand les parlers pas rester n'avait
jamais ni l'indépendance ni la terre ni
la reconnaissance aussi du monde arabe
donc à vous si vous êtes en train de
sous-estimer la lutte des palestiniens
pendant l'occupation anglaise pendant le
mandat de 1920 22 23 à 1945 à une
opposition
il ya eu des massacres mais comment il
avait eu des réunions qui se sont tenues
au caire il y avait un mouvement
palestinien extrêmement important point
de transit geisha beaucoup de respect
pour toi
vraiment mais les grandes move t.ac.a
l'est avec éclat il a collaboré wifi
qu'elle est l'hôte
il était préfet les alliances avec tout
le monde vit est celle liée à mon avis
si les mots palestinienne commencer les
négociations
les renaissances juifs renault sas
palestine commençaient à la même temps
sur la même droite c'était devenir
vraiment compréhension mutuelle entre
nous d en place on commençait le luth
qu'on n'en avait pas ni l'état ni les
raisons nous étions déjà là
alors pour vous en tous les cas
trausse boutros ghali vous dites que les
européens créer un état occidental en
terre arabe
vous parlez dans le livre et c'est là où
j'étais assez choqué quand même vous
parlez de fait colonial
vous dites que c'est comparable au
royaume des croisés sauf que dans ce cas
là il s'agit d'une une association judéo
chrétienne c'est comparable à la
présence française en algérie c'est
comparable à la présence anglaise au
kenya c'est la vision du monde arabe
il y avait pas d français en algérie et
2000 ans quand même nom met d'accord
mais si vous n'aimez rampe et 2001 il y
avait 2 ya 2000 ans il y avait les
égyptiens et les parents qui occupait
cette partie du monde en ce moment je
peux dire que c'est un territoire
égyptien
les vrais empires la palestine et elle
est hautement par le jury après elle
avait les anglais qui remplaçait l'un
pierre d'automne après les autres nous
ne l'étions pas ni un mp est né en force
et le monde juif était en catastrophe
aucun des précédents quelque chose
terrible et les anglais qui gouvernent
palestine à cette époque là mais donnez
pas la permission aussi pour les
réfugiés juive
arrivé à nice est comme ça et on ne peut
pas comparer israël avec un empire nous
n'étions pas inquiets nous étions peuple
dan catastrophe sans pareil sans
solution et nous n'avons pas aller en
israël a pressé m pour contrôler ne
verra pas de tout le monde arabe est non
alors il ya 2 il ya deux faits comme ça
qui sont étonnants dans l'ordre votre
bouche ad'abord effectivement le fait
colonial si on vous dit que c'est une
colonie finalement israël une colonie
occidentale au moyen-orient et puis vous
employez aussi le terme de nettoyage
ethnique parce que au moment où israël
est née sept cent mille palestiniens
sont partis d'eux
d'israël alors je conduis généralement
c'est pour faire place nette
on dit généralement que c'est les
gouvernements arabes alentours qui ont
dit partez parce qu'avoir une guerre
vraiment dur contre les juifs donc allez
vous en comme ça vous ne souffrirez pas
des dommages de guerre
c'est une météorite l'autre théorie
c'est ce que vous dites c'est qu'en fait
il ya eu un véritable nettoyage ethnique
opéré par les israéliens sur les
palestiniens qui habitait là et je pense
qu'il ya eu
actuellement il ya des historiens
israéliens qui le connaissent et qui
disent qu'ils nettoient y âge sont des
bouillies a fait partir ces palestiniens
savent on ne quitte pas facilement sans
villa oui j'ai été là j'ai déjà je ne
serai pas besoin de lire les histoires
j'étais à côté de ben gourion à cette
époque ben gourion donnait les ordres
pour garder tout le monde arabe en
israël
c'était les grandes moufter qui a dit
les arabes en palestine et en israël et
nous allons avec israël nous allons
gagner la guerre il faut qu'ils vous
quitter la terre et après n'aurait-on
nombre avec les grandes victoires
ce n'était pas les initiatives
israéliennes de tous est tous les livres
eux les femmes parlent comme impression
sur moi même j'ai été la plus jamais y
avait deux personnes qui étaient là qui
disent le contraire on cherche peut-être
à laver le sang tant que personne mais
je dis les choses que j'ai jamais vu
alors on en arrive au point du
terrorisme palestinien pour vous boutros
boutros ghali évidemment il n'est pas
justifié
mais il est expliqué pour vous
absolument c'est une colonie
il est normal qu'une guerre de
décolonisation et les terroristes en
fait dans ce cas là deviennent des
résistants et non plus des terroristes
des résistants au service de la cause
sacré exactement comme vous avez eu
d'été de terroristes du côté israélien
et comme vous avez
est ce que je veux proches szymon pesc
vous avez actuellement des assassinats
ciblés
vous vous avez éliminé d'une
cinquantaine de responsables
palestiniens ont les assassine ans alors
que vous avez pu les juger et vous
m'avez vous allez me répondre c'est une
action préventive pour chaque pays qui
cherchent l'indépendance il y à des
alternatives des bois le bois de grande
et nelson mandela et de voir l'intérieur
à mon avis si les mondes palestinienne
suivant l'exemple de nelson mandela
mandela on a déjà et possède un état
palestinien clair parce que c'est contre
notre tradition contre les vidéos
typiques ne voudrions pas occupés ni les
auteurs ni larbi et mais quand vous
était attaqué par les terreurs de
suicides qui est très compliqué les
médias ne sont pas simples les problèmes
s'est elle jamais n'ai commencé les
frères jamais c'est toujours en réaction
au programme action préventive contre
menace immédiat
quand vous n'avez pas le temps vous avez
eu le mot préventif que vous avez
commencé avant en disant je m'attends à
une mise d'abord apprenons prenons un
exemple ici comme dans l'exemple ci
prenant sheikh yassine par exemple qui a
été tué à partir d'un hélicoptère par
exemple vous vous considérez que c'est
du préventif shimon non à un autre show
bat cher je suis pas absolument certains
chefs de maisons organisation terroriste
clairement ils demandent elles tuer les
femmes les enfants c'est très compliqué
c'était pas une raison pour le tuer bon
nous n'avons pas tjrs et il était très
longtemps dans notre présente avec le
décodeur respect mais après ça m'est
égal nous avons nous avons trouvé qu'il
prépare notre attaque attaque
ce n'était pas seulement contre lui et
j'ai dit que cette année ils étaient
paralysés l'été balade ils avaient une
valeur symbolique elle était paralysé il
avait accepté les miels traitement
médical en israël et la tête en bon état
mais tu devrais malgré la présence d'un
imposant avec les spéciales les
conditions des conditions spéciales
présence et une prison peut coûter mais
il était le ps est complètement libre
s'il arrêtait son appel pour tuer les
peuples
d'après vous avez dans certains cas vous
les arrêter et voulait jugé bon et dans
d'autres cage voulait condamner à mort
avant même de les juger
vous les assassiner comment vous
expliquez ça j'ai pu expliquer ça parce
que aucun attaque par notre âme et
n'était pas fait sans les conseils de
notre régime sait c'est suivant les
jugements internationale chaque
condition et unique différence et chaque
attaque et jugé par le monde
de supprimer les cons enfin comment vous
allez quoi vous allez un juge va
condamner quelqu'un et à hama sans même
l'écouter sans même savoir qu'est ce
qu'il fait sans un jugement
c'était quoi ils se lèvent le matin ils
décident de le tuer tu as tes apprenait
un exemple précis
ok il y à beaucoup d autres si vous
restiez à une formation qui a quelqu'un
avec un boom dans les mains qu'il va
attaquer des minutes
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire cette
messieurs étaient 1 à 6 ans ce n'était
quelques os mais noble supprime cet été
me sied malgré son état il encourageait
les autres courtiers les peuples qui se
complique en hausse parce que vous
encourager quelqu'un que vous êtes comme
bernard encore h et il avait cep à
l'encouragement c'est à l'organisation
avec beaucoup de pouvoir les moyennes
des jours à jour après jour il faut
arrêter de vous aider vous ne pouvez pas
vous avait kidnappé un certain nombre de
chefs palestiniens
vous n'avez pas pu le kidnapper le
condamner à présent présent pourquoi
pourquoi dans certains cas voulait
kidnappé puis vous les jugez et sont
condamnés à vingt cinq ans et dans
d'autres cas vous décidez pourra
demander les a cessé s'il ya un sealyham
chance pour arrêter ces messieurs c'est
toujours préférable mais si vous n'avez
pas le temps et si vous arrivez au point
qu'elle échoir c'est un terreau mourir
oh c'est défendre et léa les règles pour
cela les choix reste vivant il n'est pas
le cher n'est pas aucun droit attaquer
quelqu'un ne pas aucun droit organisée à
l'organisation pour tuer les peuples
pourquoi vous
assassiner quelqu'un mais ces gens
donner à quelqu'un c'est pas quelqu'un
c'est un métier extrêmement dangereux
qui est responsable pour les mots il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui le détenait
les droits attaquer les femmes au taquet
les enfants qu'elles cher cela si nous
parlons sirhan leader spirituel
les premières choses respecter l'avis de
tout le monde a essayé la vie de l'exil
des menhirs à mafia
cl de venir à mafia cette mafia bien
alors en 1975 l'onu qui avaient voté
pour la naissance d'israël assimile le
sionisme au racisme alors ça a été
annulé depuis mais c'est très
intéressant de voir vos positions sur
cette décision de l'onu pour vous shimon
peres on réduit l'expression national
des juifs à une forme de racisme dont
vous trouvé ça extrêmement grave
et pour vous boutros vous dites non les
palestiniens étaient sur cette terre
depuis des siècles ils ont droit d'y
retourner ils peuvent faire tourner
alors que les juifs du monde entier
bénéficient d'un droit de retour
automatique et vous dites c'est une
discrimination
c'est un racisme religieux et ethniques
écoutez vous avez un million de
palestiniens qui ont la nationalité
israélienne et qui tangue citoyens de
second ordre
non non non une somme égale et là les
problèmes psychologiques que
j'expliquais même quelques mots d'abord
qui sont les juges et les juges qui
décident des quais et les scélérats
saison c'est beaucoup de personnes des
donations qui est elle même était
raciste qu'elle même discriminée répète
nous avons aussi un million de juifs
dans le monde arabe
on était forcé quitter les places ne
faut pas oublier cela comme ça c'est pas
un coup
complètement objecté vrai et il faut des
qui historiquement a cédé peuple tué
beaucoup de juifs et appelle les
victimes le raciste c'est en fait un
exagération des histoires de jean-yves
c'est plutôt est arabe victimes et par
quelqu'un qui discrimine et les autres
je n'ai pas pas excepté avec tout le
respect pour leurs signaux nécessaires
ou historiques
pas d'eau pas de tout la première qui a
tué mille et mille personnes dans
beaucoup d'endroits tu prenais saddam
prochaine il peut être un juge pour leur
saison
alors voilà ces entretiens croisés sont
passionnants comme vous le voyez il
couvre 60 ans d'histoire alors il ya le
voyage de sadate à jérusalem avec le
fameux discours à la knesset
vous aviez écrit un discours boutros
boutros ghali n'essaie pas celui-là
qu'il a c'est pas celui-là qu'il a dit
oui ça a été ma grande déception créé il
ya comme des villes à la paix séparée
entre israël et l'egypte dont vous avez
été un des vies d'amendé les
organisateurs il ya l'assassinât de
sadate salle a été assassiné parce qu'il
avait fait la paix avec israël je pense
parce que surtout il fut assassiné parce
qu'il avait l'opposition des
fondamentalistes ray et les
fondamentalistes parmi les reproches qui
lui faisait c'est d'avoir signé la paix
avec israël
moi alors il ya sabra et chatila alors
il ya une vraie nuance terminologique là
dessus c'est à dire que les israéliens
n'ont pas pratiqué évidemment les
massacres de sabra et chatila qui ont
été pratiqués par des milices libanaises
chrétiennes mais on parle de passivité
ou de complicité des deux voyants mais
je les no 6 dans le libre je veux donner
des choses précises gtep armés
quatre cent mille personnes qui fait une
démonstration contre chatila que la vie
c'était moi qu organiser cela comment
résultats l'homme était arrivé devant
des notaires supprime qu on donnait un
jugement il faut être précis avec les
gisements en ald et qui sait pas l'armée
israélienne qui participent et dans les
horribles où 20 des mollahs mais les
responsabilités des armées israéliennes
et mi-session c'est qu'il n'avait pas
faire les pré version wii mais il n'y
avait pas participé là pour mousses et a
été un choc mais à mon avis ils ne
paient pas compris les histoires d'état
israël 5 comprend qu'ils aient les bases
est toujours normal il n'est pas être
resté un juive
sanaa un appel moral il ya les autres
considérations
clairement il faut défendre votre avis
mais finalement c'est pour ça que nous
avons des monstres et contre chatila
parce que nous n'étions pas sûrs si nous
n'avons pas passé les line les limites
vous parlez du hamas et du jihad
islamique et finalement vous êtes assez
d'accord sur un truc c'est que leur
émergence a été favorisée par le fait
qu'israël s'est construit sur des bases
religieuses est assez d'accord là dessus
dans le bouquin je me dire que je pense
que une des raisons qui a encouragé
développement
du fondamentalisme je ne dis pas que
c'est la première ce qui se dit bon si
l'état d'israël a réussi à voir une
armée a réussi à défaire gagné tant de
victoires contre tout le monde arabe
c'est une des raisons c'est que c'était
l'état qui à pâques est basé sur une
base région donc nous aussi c'est
moulant réussir autant voir une base
religieuse est d'accord avec ça dans le
livre on peut être léger et être pour la
paix c'est sûr est à paul hameau 1 les
mots religion
demandez pas qui veut devenir une
organisation de terreur je pense qu'il
est majorité des palestiniens mais chez
nous sommes pour la paix sont pas en
rapport complètement différent on dit
toujours que c'est vrai les gir sont
capables essonne les raisons pour tous
et un nez et problème il rame
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient le fait
consternant les irakiennes attaquer les
erreurs c'est complètement des eaux
vous vous dites dans le bouquin
qu'israël n'est pas le seul promoteur de
guerre du monde arabe c'est les
fanatismes religieux pas les religions
et les fanatismes religieux est l'appli
grande problèmes de notre époque on sent
une frontale et modernité quant à chaque
personne qui est moderne cantal chaque
événement hockey moderne on veut garder
les veilles vie sans changement et c'est
impossible
terry quai et la même temps religieux
musulmans des modèles on paie temps
modernes ne peut être religieux ne parle
qu'en contradiction mais vous avez un
fondamentalisme juifs aussi
oui bien sûr mais sans les ans avec les
arguments ou et eliane différence si
vous êtes extrême s'alarme c'est un
chose mais si vous tirez à cause de
religion c'est un autre chose a pas
besoin d'utiliser les armes vous avez
utilisé pour vous dans vos assassinats
ciblés dans vos reprises alors vous
parle évidemment des accords d'oslo et
on se dit que aujourd'hui quand on
regarde la situation telle quelle et au
moyen-orient la seule question que j'ai
envie de vous poser finalement shimon
peres c'est pourquoi ça n'a pas marché
oslo la vraie raison
d'abord les grandes surprises qui sait
comment c'est ouais c'était en
introduction complètement différent de
tous les autres alors que nous avons
achevé qu'elle a abouti à quelque chose
qui est complètement important c'est la
première fois qu'il est palestinienne
était reconnu comme en paix peut on
établir une personnalité palestiniens
avec avatar ont un problème salohy
hausse on ne pouvait pas commencer avec
lui
nous ne pouvons pas terminer il
changeait son avis dans les mortiers des
routes
oui l'avenir comment boutros mais
écoutez je pense que dans le livre ce
qui m'opposait szymon placé que lui
s'éteint un optimiste et moi je suis un
pessimiste
c'est peut-être dû à mon caractère et
c'est dû à son caractère mais c'est
sacré différence parce qu'après tout si
vous voyez au début du siècle des
palestiniens avait 100% du territoire
puisant passer à 45 % puis maintenant
ils sont à 22% et je ne crois pas qu'ils
allons 22% parce que si vous ajoutez le
mur que vous avez construit ça va être
serré
ça va ça va mieux maintenant donc
écouter indépendamment de ceux ci jeu je
pense que malheureusement il faudra
attendre encore une génération avant de
pouvoir engager un véritable dialogue
je ne pense pas je pense qu'ils seront
des enfants de shimon peres qui eux pour
l'envoi la paix mais lui je ne pense pas
qu'ils avaient raté quelque chose à
boutros nous avons même âge les
optimistes
en fait tu disparaisses de la natation
mais ils vivent différemment
alors pourquoi vous restait pessimiste
presse devenons optimiste
ferrette 60 ans de conflit serait le rab
témoignage pour l'histoire c'est aux
éditions complexe
les passionne vraiment c'est vraiment
bien barré
merci
là
j'ai donc